rjust because Quentin Beck makes up lies about the multiverse doesn't mean it
isn't real doctor strange and the mole
person madness I mean what excites me
about doctor strange is what made him great in the comics that he doesn't fight
villains from this earth or even from
this universe but from the multiverse of
other dimensions so you get into all
kinds of psychedelic weirdness which
this movie is going to but when I came
and talked to Kevin about doing a sequel
I said I don't want to do just another
sequel to do a sequel if I'm going to do it
it has to go into the territory that
drew me into the Doctor Strange comics
in the first place which is how they
dipped into the Gothic and the horror
and and the horrific and we're going to
make the first scary MCU film so what's
next for him
just easy softball questions I think
yeah just some you know home economics
and cooking where and a kind of crazy
line in horror I'm really excited to be
at the dawn of this project and I think
it's vital to maintain the integrity of
humor and stuff that we had in the first
film but with this twist of horror which
I think will really have people grit is
that twist of horror going to change any
way that you approach him as a character
at all or um he'll be facing unexpected
things I think he'll be in a position
rather like the audience of not knowing
what's coming at it there was a lot of
authority to his character I thought in
the avengers iterations and even in Thor
as well so we're going back to kind of
trying to destroy him a bit I think
early days but when you have a strong
sorcerer it also helps when you have a
strong Witch and The Scarlet Witch is
appearing in this movie alongside
anything that you can tell us about how
your Disney Plus show will play into
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness I don't know if I could answer
the how but I think it's I'm really
excited to be able to link one story on
one medium and bring it into the futures
we haven't done that yet and I think
that's super unique to MCU you really
like the character of Nightmare and the
concept that the nightmare
realm is a dimension
I always thought that was one of the
that's early that's like in the first
strange tale I think that's in the
introductory episode of Doctor Strange
and I always loved that well we
decided not to do that just because
that's a bit of a complex idea to try to
introduce everything that we do
introduce and introduce the idea of
nightmares themselves as being another
dimension I hope somewhere down the line
we get to explore that except I think
that's a super cool content welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to be
my new Doctor Strange - Ghost Rider
video mostly talking about Ghost Rider
there's a lot of other Doctor Strange
2news in the supernatural MCU stuff that
they're setting up but recently you
probably saw a bunch of news
announcements about them canceling all
the Ghost Rider projects that they were
working on in favor of MCU projects so
everyone put your conspiracy hats on and
we'll break it all down we're still
doing the giant infinity saga box set
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave your
best MCU Ghost Rider theory on the video
we'll just break this down top 5 style
because there's a whole bunch of stuff
getting into what's going on with
Scarlet Witch what they're doing with
x-men mutants and then the larger MCU
horror movies that they're setting up
through Doctor Strange - like blade but
starting with number 5 Marvel and Kevin
Feige announced that they were using
Doctor Strange 2 in the Scarlet Witch
character to crack the multiverse open
wide and introduced a bunch of new types
of characters and concepts to the MCU
I've already done a couple videos about
how Marvel has already technically
canonized Scarlet Witch as a mutant in
the MCU without using the word mutant
they had to step around it before the
Fox Disney deal closed that's a moot
point now because they can do anything
they want to with mutants and x-men
characters part of the reason for doing
so much Scarlet Witch stuff and crossing
her over with Doctor Strange is just
getting into the weirder mutant x-men
Base Scarlet Witch
stories is setting some of that stuff up
for Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase 5
Doctor Strange - is meant to be the
launching platform for a bunch of
different big concepts that they haven't
done yet they confirmed they're doing
the blade movie at the big Comic Con
panel that's another good example
vampires in the MCU and now Ghost Rider
another one of their major supernatural
characters that up until now they had
not done in the MCU for in recent years
agents of shield introduced the Robbie
Rhea's version of the character he's the
third version after Johnny Blaze then
Danny ketch recently Marvel and Donnie
Cates just created the cosmic Ghost
Rider character super popular but he's a
version of Frank Castle Punisher who
becomes the next spirit of vengeance in
before the summer you all heard the news
about how Marvel television had been
developing a live-action Ghost Rider
spin-off series on Hulu starring the
agents of shield Ghost Rider and it was
meant to cover his continuing adventures
they had started to set up some really
big cosmic multiverse stuff with that
character that I'll talk about in a
second previously the character left
shield at the end of season 4 talking
about how he'd been fighting this giant
interdimensional war and that was the
shield writers way of explaining why he
wasn't around one because they couldn't
use the character in every single
episode and at the same time trying to
incorporate elements of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame
broadening the multiverse stories as
they're now doing through Doctor Strange
- in the movies this is the clip he went
out on talking about this big
multi-dimensional conflict that he was
fighting in dimensions space planets
it's all connected plenty of them
qualify as health
the earth is just one territory in a war
that's been going on forever they did a
pretty decent job with a character for
the budget that they had as you go with
that saying that the MCU version of
Ghost Rider when they do introduce him
is going to be way way bigger but if you
didn't watch that season of agents of
shield they did do a version of Johnny
Blaze and Danny ketch with some
cutscenes and Easter eggs for Robbie ray
is his origin story so they were doing
comic book
Ghost Rider backstory eventually the
idea was they would use that Ghost Rider
spin-off series they were doing on Hulu
to explain more about the cosmic
multiverse story they had been setting
up with his character three I recently
did a video about how Marvel now
completely just changed everything about
the way it handles TV shows in the last
couple of months Kevin Feige was
promoted to oversee all aspects of
storytelling from Marvel so he's in
charge of all Marvel television shows
all Marvel movies and now all Marvel
Comics when that happened he snapped a
ton of marble TV shows including the
Ghost Rider TV show that he himself did
not develop like he didn't have any hand
in developing that Robbie Reyes version
of Ghost Rider for agents of shield
formally Marvel said that they in Hulu
had just parted ways and wouldn't be
going forward because of quote-unquote
creative differences but put your
conspiracy hats back on because what's
really going on is now the vast majority
of Marvel's new TV shows will come
through Disney Plus be really big-budget
and totally connected to the MCU like
when daredevil comes back he'll be MCU
daredevil the same is true for Ghost
Rider
so to Marvel doesn't have any plans for
another solo Ghost Rider movie right now
but as Kevin Feige recently explained
what he was talking about vampires and
bladed the MCU that they'd always
planned on eventually doing all these
supernatural characters after they'd
done their homework setting up the
concepts using the Doctor Strange movies
and Doctor Strange to is just the next
example of that this is him
talking about why they waited so long we
have for years
wanted to find a new way into blade we
love that character we love that world
now with Doctor Strange and the
supernatural elements coming into the
MCU it felt like we could we could
definitely start exploring that
mahalo once come in and meet with us
and when Mohali wants to meet you take
the meeting and I think he had just come
off of his second Academy Award and we
were talking very polite and he was
talking about what a fanny is and then
he just cut right to it and was like
blade and we're like yes as he implies
they had big plans for horror and
supernatural character movies blade is
just the next one that's getting his own
solo movie Doctor Strange too in the
blade franchise is where you'll see all
those types of characters being set up
for the first time before they start
crossing over with other characters
that's why it should have been no
surprise that right after the news about
them cancelling the Ghost Rider TV show
news about them setting up the concept
of MCU Ghost Rider in Doctor Strange 2
started happening like oh of course
Kevin Feige is taking the Ghost Rider
character back because he totally has
plans for that character in these movies
the same is true of x-men and Scarlet
Witch you set up the concept of mutants
in doctor strange - when you're talking
about these really supernatural horror
based concepts you get into the really
weird stuff so that it doesn't seem so
weird when you actually do an x-men
movie at a couple more years so right
now my early prediction for Ghost Rider
showing up in the MCU are that when
Doctor Strange and Scarlet Witch are
traveling the multiverse during Doctor
Strange to battling nightmare as it
sounds like he's the villain like Scott
Derrickson is saying during that clip
they said if the concept of the spirit
of vengeance the idea of Ghost Rider and
set up the concept of vampires and other
types of supernatural creatures
nightmare the character is one of the
fear Lords and the dimensions that they
rule over are sort of adjacent to each
other in adjacent to the ground where
Mephisto and the spirit of vengeance
come from the spirit of vengeance flows
from Mephisto he's the person that gave
Johnny Blaze the spirit of vengeance in
the first place but number one because
right now blade doesn't even have a
release date I'm expecting it's going to be
sometime between 2022-2023
really soon after these
Marvel phase 4 movies and Black
Panther 2 which they do have specific
dates for but let me know how you want
them to handle the Ghost Rider character
just in general in the movies when they
do introduce him while I was making this
video they confirm that ant-man the wasp
3 is moving forward at Marvel so they're
making that movie I'll do a video about
that next so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that video when I post it so everybody
click here for that brand new Avengers 5
announcement
click here for the boys season 2 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!